foreign
today we will take you through the hands
of live demo of how you can detect
Parkinson's disease using python
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them so
wait for some more minutes to let other
people join until then let me tell you
guys that we have regular updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek on a continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press that Bell icon to never miss
any updates from Simply learn
okay great I think we can get started so
in today's session we will go through
the hands of lab demo of how you can
detect Parkinson's disease using machine
learning we will perform different
function and analyze the data set using
python to find who has Parkinson's
disease and who has not using different
different python libraries
before we move on to the programming
part so here is one question for you
guys
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answer is given by you are
right or wrong
so the question is which of the
following character is used to give
single line comments in Python
option A double slash option b hash
option C star option D slash star let us
know your answer in the chat section
so I am starting the timer of one minute
you can just type your answer in the
comment section or in the chat section
so I'm starting the timer of one minute
let us know in your answer in the chat
section
foreign
characters used to give single line
comments in Python
double slash has star slash star
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this
which of the following characters is
used to give single line comments in
Python
15 seconds remaining which of the
following characters used to give single
line comments in Python
one
after the allotted time has passed Those
Who provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one now let's move to our
programming part to implement
prediction system of Parkinson's disease
so first we will open a command prompt
to write command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select a new Python 3
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a prediction
system of Parkinson's disease
so I will write here first I will rename
this
Parkinson
prediction
so I will write here
quote
numpy
as NP
and the second one is import
pandas as PD
and the next one is
from sqln
port
svm
then from
SK learn
dot matrix
import
accuracy
underscore then score
after that from
Escalon
Dot pre-processing
import
standard
scalar
then from
SK learn
dot model
underscore selection
port
train
underscore test
underscore split
then press enter yeah
so numpa is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has function
for working in the domain of linear
algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
and the second version pandas
panda is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operations
for manipulating numerical tables and
Time series
Escalon the most effective and reliable
python machine learning library is
called sqln or scikitlan
through a python consistency interface
it offers a variety of effective tools
for statical modeling and machine
learning including classification
regression and many more
svm svmr utilized in web pages and
chosen detection phase identification
email Gene classification and
handwriting recognition
among other applications we utilize svm
in machine learning for some reason
including this
both classification and regression
linear and non-linear data are supported
Escalon matrices the SQL and matrices
module implements several laws score and
utility function to measure
classification performance
some matrices might require probability
estimate of the positive class
configuration value or binary decision
value
and the next one is accuracy score in
Python the accuracy score function of
the sqln matrices package calculates the
accuracy score for a set of predicted
labels against the true labels
SQL and pre-processing the SQL and
pre-processing package offers a number
of universal utility function and
Transformer classes to modify
unprocessed feature vectors into a
format better suited for the subsequent
estimators in general standardizing the
data set in advantages for learning
algorithm
then standard scalar each feature of
variable is scaled to unit variance once
standard scalar has is moved this mean
this process is carried out
independently based on features since
standard scalar estimate the empirical
mean and standard deviation of each
feature if they are present in the data
set
and the last one is train test split
python train test split method divides
array or matrices into random sepsis
for the train and test set of data we
will import the train test split
function into our application as shown
import the train test split variable
from the sqln model selection
so after importing major libraries let's
import data set
so for that we will write here
DF equals to
PD dot read
underscore CSV
sorry CSV
then data set name
disease
dot CSV
you can download this data set from the
description box below so let's see our
data set now so here I will write DF
so this is how our data set looks like
with 195 rows and 24 columns
so here you can see like we can't see
all the 195 rows okay like top five rows
and
so
here you can see the three dots
this three dots but if I want to see all
the 195 rows so for that I will write
here
Ed dot set
let's go option
display
dot Max
underscore columns
here I will write PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
close
comma none
and here I will write the data set name
DF
yeah
so you can see now we are unable to see
the all the 195 rows
okay
all the 195 rows
so moving forward we will use head
function to see only top five rows
so first I will do like this
okay here I will write
DF dot head
so here you can see we can see only top
five rows of our data set
so
so basically head is used for showing
first five rows of the data set
if we will use tail instead of head so
it will show last five rows of the data
set
so let's move forward and see
and using info function to see the
information about the data set
so I will write here DF dot info
yeah
so the data frame information is printed
by the info method the data includes the
total number of columns their labels
data kinds memory use raise index and
the number of cells in each column like
non-null values note that the info
method does not indeed print the
information
okay so we all know all the column names
and the data for types so here you can
see these are the column names and
non-null values then data types
okay
yeah so moving forward let's see some
statical values using describe function
so for that I will write DF Dot describe
press enter yeah
so here you can see all the statical
values of every column like mean
standard deviation count like 25 percent
50 percent 75 percent the maximum value
of that particular column okay for every
column
so moving forward let's see how many
columns and rows are present in the data
set using the shape function
for that I will write here
DF dot shape
so here you can see we have 195 rows and
24 columns present in our data set
okay like 190 it represents
rows and this represents columns okay
so moving forward we will see how many
null values are present in the data set
so for that we will write
DF dot is null
then dot sum
then press enter
is showing data frame objects here oh
sorry for that
this is is null
yeah then press enter yeah
so here you can see there is no null
values present in our data set no zero
zero Z all the zeros are there
so we can say this is a good data set
okay
so I will just
yeah so moving forwards we will
distribute our Target variable columns
okay
so for that I have to write here DF
status
status is our Target variable okay
Target column
dot value
underscore
counts
and press enter yeah
so here you can see zeros and ones like
147 ones and zeros are zero sorry 48 are
0.
so one means those who are affected by
the Parkinson and 0 means negative those
who are not affected by the Parkinson's
disease
so moving forward what we will do we
will group database on the target
variable okay so for that I have to
write here DF dot Group by
then status
dot mean
yeah
so here you can see that we group data
based on the target variable for each
column for each column
all the 24 columns okay
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code like any code till
here
so you can just put us in comments or
our team will surely provide you the
correct solution okay
so moving forward like we what we will
do we will separate features and Target
variable
so what we will do we will drop the two
columns like first one is name column
and the second one is status column and
in another variable we will put status
column
let's see
I have to write x equals to
at DF dot drop
then columns
equals to
first one is name
and the second one is
status
okay
comma X is equals to
1.
then in y
I will put
DF
status
so let's print X and Y
so I will print here
print
y here
yeah
so here you can see all the X values
and here you can see all these status
value like zeros and ones only
zeros and ones okay
let me do this yeah
so moving forward we will split data set
into training and testing using train
test split function
so for that we will write
X
underscore train
comma X
underscore test
comma
y underscore train
comma
y underscore test
also
train underscore test underscore split
comma y comma
test
underscore
size
equals to 0.2
comma
random underscore State equals to 2.
yeah
so here what I did I split training and
testing data into 80 and 20 ratio eighty
percent for training data and twenty
percent for testing
in prediction like this is the best
ratio
so moving forward let's see how many
rows and columns are present in training
data and in testing data so for that I
have to write your print
dot shape
comma
X underscore train
dot shape
comma X underscore test dot ship
yeah
so here you can see
like in training and testing there are
22 columns why because we already
dropped two columns name and status
okay let me show you first
and we checked this before there are 24
columns okay
so now we have only 22 volumes why
because we dropped the name and Status
column
so X train has 156 rows this 156 rows
why this is 80 percent of 195. okay and
this is 20 of 195. this is training this
is testing
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code or any machine
learning topic and python so you what
you can do just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
so moving forward what we will do we
will do data standardization okay
so the process of transforming data into
a standardized format so that user may
process and evaluate it is known as data
standardization
most businesses use data from a variety
of sources including databases data
warehouse Lakes cloud storage and
storage areas
okay so for that I will write SS equals
to
standard
killer
we all know what is standard scalar
yeah so press enter
so we use a standard scalar for it so I
will write here SS dot bit
then X underscore train SS means
standard scalar okay
don't confuse yeah so using standard
scalar we fit training data into it so
moving forward we will transform
training data and testing data using
standard scalar Library okay so I will
write here x underscore train
equals SS dot transform
let's go train
yeah
then X underscore test
equals to SS SS means standard scalar
dot transform
test
yeah then press enter
so transformation is done now let's see
our training and testing data for that I
will write here print
X underscore train
so this is our training data
and print
X underscore test
so this is our testing data okay
yeah so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or any machine
learning topic just put us in comments
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution so moving forward we
will train our model using svm method
SMR utilized in web pages intrusion
dissection page identification email
Gene classification and handwriting
recognition among other application we
utilize svms in machine learning for
some reason including this
okay so we will do model training using
like svm so I will write a model
equals to
svm dot SVC
that will write a kernel
question
linear
and press enter
okay
sqln.svm has no attribute SVC okay my
bad
C is capital
okay let me check
okay
should be small
then press enter yeah now it's working
fine
so let's train svm with training data so
for that I will write here
model dot fit
X
underscore train
comma y underscore train then press
enter
yeah it's working fine
so moving forward what we will do we
will do model evaluation so for that I
have to write here x underscore
then train
underscore
prediction
equals to model Dot
predict
X underscore train
train underscore data
accuracy equals to accuracy
underscore score
y underscore train
and then
X underscore train
then
prediction
let me do one thing I have to write D
here
for the better understanding
yeah then press enter from this we what
we are doing we are doing prediction and
checking the accuracy of the model svm
so like we will check accuracy for both
training and testing data okay yeah so
let me check first print
accuracy of
training
data
data
here I have to write train
underscore data
underscore
accuracy
press enter
so the accuracy of training data is
almost 89 percent like which is not a
bad number
so let's check accuracy of the testing
data
so for that I have to write here x
underscore test underscore prediction
equals to model
dot predict
then X
test underscore data
underscore accuracy
equals to accuracy
score
y underscore test
comma
X underscore test
prediction
yeah
so now let's see the accuracy of testing
data so for that type light print
accuracy of testing
data
test
code data underscore accuracy
so here you can see the accuracy of
testing data is almost 88 percent so
we're done with the model building and
the accuracy part so let's build
predictive system now
okay for that
I will write
okay first let me do one thing yeah
so I will write here input
data
okay
and we will change data into numpy array
so for that we will write input
underscore data underscore NP equals to
NP dot as array
and input
underscore data
okay
so now what we will do
we will reshape this array
okay we will receive this number array
for that I will write input underscore
data
underscore for a shape I will write only
re
so input
underscore data
score NP
dot reshape
then
1 2
minus 1.
okay
so now we will standardize the data for
that I will write here s underscore data
equals to SS dot transform
input
underscore data underscore
so now I will make prediction model
prediction equals to
model dot predict
the standardized digital so as data
so you have to print
question
so for that I have to write here if
if prediction
zero equals to equals to zero
okay
then it should be print print
negative
no
Parkinson's
okay
else
print
positive
Parkinson
Parkinson's found
so we are done with the our coding part
so what we will do I will go on the my
data set
open with Notepad
so this is our data set okay we will put
any random value
like this value okay
yeah
put it here
so here you can see the status value to
the zero
so
zero means negative no Parkinson found
it should print no Parkinson found so
what I will do I will remove this to
check whether model is giving
the right answer or wrong then press
enter yeah
here you can see it printed Parkinson
found
so now we will check from the another
one
we'll take the random
we'll pick
we'll pick this one
I will remove this status value
then press enter
okay something error one error picture
okay okay okay okay
let me copy it again
the
then
copy it again here
we'll remove this
and then press enter
yeah here you can see positive Parkinson
found because there is one status is one
so so you can see the results are coming
amazing and correct so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
so just put us in comments
just ignore this warning
okay
I hope you guys must understood the
concept of how we can detect Parkinson's
disease using machine learning
if you have any queries you can ask in
the comment section below our team will
respond you as soon as possible and if
you want this full code just comment for
the same
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this video please do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and give a like
to this video thank you and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here